[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out
what happened joe biden was sworn in
this week as the 46th
president of the united states that's
right it's out with the old and in with
the elderly
vice president kamala harris on
wednesday became the first female black
and asian american person
to hold the office making her the first
vice president who i know has been to a
sally beauty supply
i'll see you there singer lady gaga
performed the national anthem at
wednesday's inauguration ceremony
and then she was carried away by her
brooch
oh goodbye bye bye you did a good job
yeah
singer garth brooks performed the song
amazing grace at the inauguration
ceremony
while wearing a pair of jeans which just
goes to show
you can take the boy out of the country
but white men will wear jeans to
anything
chris gaines may who dressed him
chris gaines chris gaines i think so
yeah he needs to bring
chris gaines back now if you
know who chris gaines is please tweet it
terry
tweeted derek i love chris gaines as
much as you do
um before i mean you knew the first and
last names
yeah i would say you know that guy but
you just
i know it's it it will never leave my
brain he had a soul patch she had the
hair
father totally tried to convince us he
was a different person and i'm
here for it [ __ ] he fooled me yeah
before leaving the white house this week
donald trump left a note for president
biden in the oval office and we have a
copy of it
washington state this week launched an
online tool to help residents figure out
when they can get the coronavirus
vaccine the way it works is if you know
how to use an online tool it's not your
turn yet
federal regulators recently announced a
recall of hot pockets over concerns they
may contain pieces of glass
instead of what they normally contain
cheese the same temperature as the sun
and finally according to a recent study
the world's oldest
discovered cave art may be a 45
500 year old painting of a pig and it's
beautiful
i did not write that joke i do not
condone
the telling of that joke shame on
whoever wrote it
but i did laugh very hard and that was
the monologue
did you like the monologue i did good
cause that was your birthday present
okay oh what's that that is the good
news alarm
amber do you have some good news i do
i wrote a book with my sister and this
week it became a new york times best
[Music]
seller never believe what happened to
lacey
crazy stories about racism and it's full
of crazy stories about
things people have said to my sister
lacey while she's busy minding her own
business
now you can get it wherever you like to
buy books hey
what kind of book is it again it's the
new york times bestseller
yeah all right everybody calm down
there's enough of that mess
now obviously the biggest news of the
week was the inauguration but
america didn't just get a new president
and vice president
we also got an entirely new slate of
cabinet officials so
we wanted to take a moment to show you
who's taking over for whom in a segment
we call
out with the old and in with the new
[Music]
first up you may recognize trump's
secretary of state mike pompeo
he's famous for screwing up our
relationship with iran and yelling at
journalists
well move over mike because there's a
new secretary
of state in town and his name is anthony
blinken i only know that because i'm
reading it off the screen right now
i have never seen this man before and i
hope to never see him again
and if he does his job well that's
exactly what will happen
next up trump's treasury secretary was
human beaker muppet steve mnuchin he was
terrible at his job but
those days are over because now we've
got this lady
now if you're really tapped into the
news you might recognize her face and
even know her name
i want to say judy oh and that's okay
in fact it's freaking awesome next up
secretary of education betsy devos
i for one am sick of talking about her
and i'm looking forward to
whoever the hell this is oh looks nice i
like his goatee
and that's as much as i would ever like
to know about this man
now i'm not saying we shouldn't give him
the credit he deserves or hold him
accountable when he makes mistakes
but if i have to learn his name at some
point fine but not today
today he's just a nice guy with a goatee
[Laughter]
derek he has a beautiful goatee just
like you oh
commerce secretary wilbur ross is being
replaced by what's her butt
health and human services secretary alex
azar is being replaced by ole woozy
woodsy
and acting secretary of transportation
stephen bradbury is being replaced
by cheston's husband and finally rudy
giuliani is being replaced by
absolutely no one damn that feels good
this has been out with the old in with
the new
[Music]
now when president joe biden
oh that has a nice ring to it doesn't it
president
joe biden it does anyway when president
joe biden was sworn in on wednesday
it gave our country a fresh start and
with new beginnings in the air it's time
for me to start fresh as well
to do that i need to come clean about a
few things in a segment called
the lies we tell ourselves
when i soak a pot in my kitchen sink my
husband thinks i'm doing it
to make it easier for me to clean later
but in reality
i'm just hoping he'll do it that was
brave
um i i'd like to come clean about a few
things too
if anyone ever asked me what i like
about jazz i always say
coal train but i have actually no idea
what that means
sometimes when i write i hope this email
finds you well
i'm lying i hope it doesn't find you at
all i would actually like to stop
talking to people
all together
if we're having a conversation and you
mention anything about how much money
you spend on a major utility or rent
i'm not listening anymore because i'm
mentally doing the math to figure out
how much money you make in a year
if anyone ever asks me if i'm hungry and
i say i can eat
i'm lying i'm always starving always
there is never a moment where i would
not like a snack
my first thought when i walk into any
room is is there a crudite or
charcuterie platter
i've said the phrase your baby is so
cute
a million times but i have never meant
it once
i meant it once but the baby was not a
human
that's your truth and you are living and
thriving
i'm sorry what thriving yeah i also
pronounce thriving is thriving
so you can say thriving you just don't
want to exactly
wow doesn't it feel good to get that off
your chest you better believe it
this has been the lies we tell ourselves
[Music]
the inauguration on wednesday went down
pretty much as you'd expect
biden said the oath he gave a speech he
waved he said words like country and
democracy and hope and
never strayed once from the teleprompter
and if this is the kind of thing we can
expect from his presidency
well i have just one thing to say
some presidents take residence inside
your brain
their escapades leave you afraid and
full of shame but i
insist those awful days are through
yes biden i've been waiting
for you too
for me daddy bore me all night long
bore me hard bore me good bring one of
your friends along
to for me daddy but don't make me
beg you know you've got just what i need
joe button bore my
brains out
your dribble will leave civil rights
like
mine intact your laws will give no pause
cause they're a snooze yes i
believe these awful days are through
i've been fighting
my time until you
bought me daddy bore me all night long
bore me hard bore me good bring one of
your friends along
to for me daddy but don't make me
beg you know you've got just what i need
joe biden for my brains out
there is no way that i can be distressed
by biden's state of the union address
it's one boring tweet after the next
i think i'm starting not to feel so damn
depressed
you've got to
leave daddy for me long pull me
hard hold me good bring one of your
friends
you know you've got just what i need for
me daddy boy bring one of your friends
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
you